Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Et là, salut tout le monde, ravi de vous retrouver pour cette nouvelle saison de Septante Minutes Avec.
Comme vous l'avez sans doute remarqué, j'ai fait une longue, longue pause estivale pour un paquet de raisons. Déjà l'invité que je devais recevoir a été obligé de reporter malheureusement.
Puis de mon côté, je démarrais aussi un nouveau boulot, ce qui m'a demandé pas mal de concentration. Et enfin, voilà, la pandémie restait toujours un obstacle pour booker de nouveaux invités.
Mais la bonne nouvelle, c'est que tout ça, c'est derrière nous, ou presque. Et Septante Minutes peut enfin faire sa rentrée.
Je vous parlerai des prochains épisodes à la fin de cette interview, y a tout un programme pour les prochains mois.
Mais avant ça, quelques mots sur l'interview que vous êtes sur le point d'écouter. Je pense qu'à ce stade, vous avez vu le titre, vous avez choisi de lancer l'épisode, vous avez une idée des questions qui vont être abordées.
L'islamophobie, c'est un sujet sérieux dont on a tous conscience, mais si on ne le vit pas, on est difficilement en mesure de comprendre de quoi il relève exactement.
Et en plus de ça, il y a un phénomène récurrent, et c'était tout le sujet de la carte blanche de Florence Zano, amie du podcast, il y a un an.
C'est que pour parler de la communauté musulmane, du port du foulard et de toutes ces questions, souvent, on va interroger des politiciens dont c'est le terrain de jeu favori, des militants du centre laïque, etc.
Mais on va rarement prendre le temps d'écouter les personnes concernées. Et c'est ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui. Enfin, dernière précision,
que ce soit quand j'ai interviewé Rokhaya Diallo il y a un an ou Corinne Torrekens, y a quelque chose qui est très clair à mes yeux et que je dois vous avouer : je suis très loin d'être à l'aise pour traiter des questions raciales.
Ce sont des problématiques que je ne vis pas dans ma vie de tous les jours, sur lesquelles je suis très ignorant.
Et du coup, dans l'interview qui va suivre, vous verrez que je reste relativement en retrait et que je laisse la parole à mes deux invitées.
C'est fait exprès. Allez, on se retrouve juste après. Let's go. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Kaoutar Boustani et Khadija Senhadji.
Kaoutar, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Khadija, bonjour.
Nous allons parler ensemble le temps, voilà, de septante minutes, des questions liées de près ou de loin à l'islamophobie, à l'intersectionnalité et aux colonialités.
Tout particulièrement, je pense, on va se servir de l'actualité des dernières semaines et des derniers mois, en particulier ce qui concernait donc Ihsane Haouach.
Est-ce que, avant de se lancer, je peux vous demander à toutes les deux de vous présenter, en commençant par exemple par Kaoutar ?
Oui, donc je suis analyste en sciences politiques, économiques et sociales. J'habite à Bruxelles, je suis née à Bruxelles.
Super, merci. Et Khadija ?
Donc moi, je suis socio-anthropologue de formation. Je suis également Bruxelloise de naissance et je suis également militante décoloniale.
Super. J'ai hâte de discuter de ces questions avec vous puisque je pense que vous avez toutes les deux énormément de choses à nous apprendre de par vos expériences vis-à-vis de l'islamophobie.
Avant de se lancer, j'aimerais vous demander à toutes les deux ce qui vous a amené à prendre la parole sur ces questions et à ne pas finalement rester
passives en tant que femmes minorisées, femmes opprimées dans, voilà, le contexte islamophobe dont on va discuter.
Si je pose la question à Khadija, qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à prendre la parole publiquement ?
Sur les questions liées à l'islamophobie, je pense qu'à un moment donné, voilà, c'est une question, je pense que c'est une question de dignité en fait, tout simplement.
Donc ce sont des questions qui nous touchent de plein fouet dans nos existences, dans notre dignité, dans nos identités, dans ce qu'on a de plus cher finalement, nos familles, nos proches, voilà.
Donc l'islamophobie, c'est quelque chose qui représente des attaques constantes, à la fois d'ordre symbolique, d'ordre matériel, d'ordre politique.
Et donc c'est une question, je dirais, à la fois de dignité, de survie, tout simplement, que de devoir se positionner sur ces questions-là.
Donc c'est absolument pas une coquetterie intellectuelle ou une,
ou quelque chose, voilà, un passe-temps qu'on ferait comme ça, mais c'est—
je crois que c'est de l'ordre de la nécessité à un moment donné que de devoir se positionner, même si on n'a pas envie de se retrouver dans le débat public, mais on y est
forcément contraint parce que ça touche à des choses extrêmement fondamentales dans nos êtres et nos existences.
Kaoutar, est-ce que vous vous reconnaissez dans ce qui vient d'être dit ?
Oui, absolument. C'est
exactement ça. Donc quand on est atteint dans notre chair,
mais aussi dans notre communauté, dans notre vivre ensemble, et que notre dignité est bafouée, ben on se sent, disons, contraint d'intervenir de manière militante pour dire : « Ça suffit ».
Et je pense que ça veut pas dire que— bon, par exemple, la génération de nos parents n'était pas forcément militante, mais ça veut pas dire qu'ils ont moins subi d'islamophobie.
Mais nous, nous sommes une génération qui comprenons les enjeux, les phénomènes dans la société. Et donc, par rapport à ça, on se sent l'obligation de prendre en main, disons, la,
la militance ou le combat, la lutte
pour récupérer notre honneur, notre dignité, de la manière qu'il faut, puisque le droit prévoit que nous avons une place et que nous avons le droit d'exister en tant que personne, avec nos convictions,
notre culture, avec notre background culturel et tout ce qui s'ensuit, et même de manière communautaire d'ailleurs.
Et donc c'est ce qui fait qu'à un moment donné, on se retrouve sur le terrain militant, même si, je dois l'avouer, parfois aussi, moi, par exemple, j'aurais aimé ne pas avoir à militer.
J'aurais aimé passer du temps à faire ce que j'ai envie de faire, la photo, voilà, lire des romans ou des choses ainsi.
Mais voilà, on est contraint,
parfois au prix de la violence qu'on doit subir en tant que personne parce qu'on subit du harcèlement ou autre chose, mais on estime que c'est un combat qui en vaut la peine parce que voilà, la dignité n'a pas de prix.
Je vais peut-être poser la question autrement. Si on imagine maintenant une femme, voilà, musulmane, bruxelloise, voilà, un profil semblable au vôtre, mais qui n'a pas choisi
de se lever contre l'islamophobie publiquement, d'en faire un combat public,
qu'est-ce qui expliquerait la différence entre cette femme-là et vous, finalement ?
Bon, en réalité, notre ancrage social fait qu'on a connaissance du fait qu'une très large majorité des femmes comme nous partagent notre avis et partagent un peu ce sentiment de vivre de l'injustice.
Et voilà, tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes capacités ou les mêmes moyens d'agir. Et donc, voilà, les personnes qui se trouvent sur le terrain militant, c'est un peu une forme de,
voilà, de choix personnel par rapport à ce que nous avons comme— à notre disposition.
J'imagine par exemple que si j'étais médecin, j'aurais pas eu forcément le même parcours militant que
maintenant que je suis analyste en sciences politiques, économiques et sociales et que, par ailleurs, je me retrouve souvent sur des terrains, disons, de lutte politique.
Mais j'insiste sur le fait que, donc en tant que femme musulmane qui subit, on va dire, l'islamophobie, je n'ai jamais eu de personnes qui me disent : « Non, en fait, il faudrait pas militer.
» Il suffit de vivre— J'veux dire, le sentiment de l'atteinte à la dignité et d'injustice, il est très très majoritairement partagé.
Oui. Moi, j'ajouterais quelque chose qui me semble aussi très important, c'est que
l'islamophobie, comme n'importe quel phénomène en fait de racisme institutionnel, systémique, structurel, induit des formes de dépolitisation, en fait, parmi les populations qui sont visées par ces formes de racisme-là.
Et donc ça, c'est vraiment quelque chose que l'on retrouve parmi les populations minorisées. Y a toute une série de facteurs qui font qu'à un moment donné, ben, on n'a pas les ressources en fait,
matérielles ou autres, que pour pouvoir s'engager, s'organiser politiquement, puisque la lutte politique nécessite aussi une organisation en tant que telle.
Et donc ce phénomène de dépolitisation fait que effectivement, malgré
le sentiment donc d'indignité qui est massivement partagé et vécu parmi ces populations-là, eh bien, la riposte au niveau politique et l'organisation politique reste quand même fortement timide.
Mais ça ne veut pas dire, comme Kaoutar le disait, que ce n'est pas soutenu ou que ce n'est pas partagé.
Je crois que c'est vraiment une question plutôt de ressources. Quand on lutte au quotidien pour avoir accès à l'emploi, pour lutter contre les violences policières, pour que son enfant aille dans une école
qui soit digne d'un enseignement de qualité, ben, ça laisse très peu de marge finalement que pour pouvoir avoir accès à des réseaux d'organisations militantes, d'organisations politiques.
Et donc finalement, voilà, cet effet-là est un des effets pour moi du racisme que l'on subit en fait.
C'est très intéressant. Comme je le disais, on va se servir de l'actualité récente et en particulier de ce qui a eu lieu concernant Ihsane Haouach ces derniers mois.
Pour revenir un petit peu sur ce qui s'est passé, donc je rappelle que Ihsane Haouach a été désignée comme commissaire auprès de l'Institut pour l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes par la secrétaire d'État Sarah Schlitz.
À ce stade dans l'histoire, il y a déjà eu une série de, une levée de boucliers au nom d'une certaine neutralité de l'État.
On va revenir là-dessus. Il y a eu une série de controverses, une série de, voilà, beaucoup d'énervement auprès de certaines personnalités politiques, auprès d'un certain électorat.
Et puis, voilà, notamment une interview dans Le Soir où, voilà, je me permettrai de dire qu'elle a sans doute commis quelques erreurs en termes de communication.
Et suite à cela, il y a eu apparemment une enquête au sein de la Sûreté belge.
Et à partir du moment où il a été révélé qu'une enquête était en cours à son sujet,
à partir du moment où son nom était vraiment sali, puisque voilà, il y avait ces,
ces accusations d'une soi-disant proximité avec les Frères musulmans, Madame Haouach a fait le choix de se retirer de la vie publique et de la vie politique.
Et très rapidement après, la Sûreté belge a confirmé qu'il n'y avait en réalité aucune sorte de proximité entre Ihsane Haouach et les Frères musulmans.
Oui, si je reviens, moi, à la genèse, finalement, de cette affaire,
elle s'inscrit dans un contexte politique qui était déjà tendu à Bruxelles, puisque on venait d'avoir l'ordonnance Tib qui avait été adoptée,
avec une division dans le champ politique en fait, surtout francophone, au sein des partis même, notamment au sein du PS, au sein d'Ecolo, qui étaient divisés, voilà, sur la ligne à adopter parce que, bah, ça,
ça fait écho à des, j'veux dire, à des franges électorales aussi qui peuvent s'affronter au sein de ces partis-là, entre la Wallonie, Bruxelles, qui est une ville beaucoup plus diverse, où l'électorat
musulman joue un rôle important dans le maintien d'un parti comme le PS, par exemple.
En Wallonie, ben, c'est un électorat qui a une composition socio-démographique tout à fait autre et qui peut présenter une certaine hostilité aussi par rapport à,
à des questions comme l'islam, la visibilité des musulmans.
Donc y avait déjà une tension qui était
palpable et qui, à mon sens, dénotait aussi une espèce de,
euh, panique politique par rapport à non seulement la visibilité de l'islam qui n'est pas— 'fin, c'est une question qui n'est pas neuve,
mais aussi à l'accès en fait des musulmans à toute une série de fonctions en fait et de notabilité, de fonctions de prestige avec ce débat : est-ce qu'il faut interdire
le port du foulard pour toutes les fonctions ?
Est-ce qu'il faut l'autoriser uniquement dans le back-office, c'est-à-dire là où ce n'est pas visible, mais ça exclut aussi toutes les fonctions d'autorité.
Donc y avait vraiment tout ce débat-là. Et donc la nomination d'Ihsane Haouach intervient juste à la suite de cette ordonnance au moment où le débat fait encore, fait encore rage.
Et c'est vu comme une provocation par certains acteurs politiques, notamment, côté MR, Georges-Louis Bouchez, mais il n'a pas été le seul.
Et puis la machine s'est évidemment
emballée avec ce que vous avez cité, donc les différents événements, la,
la prise de parole d'Ihsane dans la presse et puis cette enquête de la Sûreté de l'État qui a marqué donc un point de non-retour et la démission et finalement la révélation que,
tout ça n'était que du vent.
Finalement, il n'y avait strictement rien dans ce rapport qui justifiait que la machine se soit emballée de cette façon-là.
Y a également le rôle que les médias ont pu jouer dans cette affaire-là. Et ça, c'est important aussi.
Ça montre combien l'islamophobie n'est pas un phénomène de racisme qui est diffus et qui prend racine à la base, c'est-à-dire un racisme populaire qui pourrait
s'ancrer dans le ressentiment comme on a tendance souvent à présenter le racisme hein, que c'est simplement une peur de l'autre, une méconnaissance de l'autre.
Non, l'islamophobie en tant que telle, c'est un phénomène qui est vraiment orchestré plutôt par les franges dominantes, à la fois au niveau politique, à la fois au niveau médiatique.
Et si on prend le rôle que le quotidien Le Soir, plus spécifiquement, a joué dans cette affaire-là, eh bien ça devient tout à fait explicite et limpide.
Le Soir, non seulement par rapport à cette interview d'Ihsane Haouach. Alors bon, on peut dire effectivement que, considérer qu'elle aurait commis des maladresses ou quoi ou qu'est-ce.
En tout cas, quand on s'appelle Ihsane Haouach et qu'on prétend un poste de commissaire du gouvernement, manifestement, on n'a droit à aucune erreur au niveau médiatique lorsqu'on communique publiquement.
Ça, c'est déjà une première chose. Et puis surtout le rôle que Le Soir a joué dans les révélations,
par rapport à ce fameux rapport,
de la Sûreté de l'État, donc en alimentant vraiment la polémique et en laissant croire qu'il y avait quelque chose de tout à fait probant et des preuves tout à fait probantes dans ce rapport, ce qui n'était absolument pas le cas.
Oui, donc il y avait effectivement la révélation par la presse de l'existence de ce rapport et de cette enquête qui, voilà, laissait imaginer au public qu'il y avait anguille sous roche.
Il y a aussi la question de la fuite. C'est vraiment, normalement, bien que ce type de rapport puisse exister tout à fait légalement,
le problème qui est posé, c'est comment la Sûreté de l'État peut laisser fuiter de telles informations concernant une personne dans un contexte particulier comme vient de le souligner Khadija.
Et en fait, Ihsane Haouach s'est retrouvée un petit peu
en point de concentration, de cristallisation de tout ce qu'on se permet de manière générale envers les musulmans et plus particulièrement envers les musulmanes, c'est-à-dire des attaques,
voilà, des accusations d'appartenance à des mouvements obscurs avec des projets cachés, des, voilà, avec des objectifs particuliers envers la société et qui relèvent du fantasme en fait hein, totalement.
Elle s'est retrouvée à être accusée de porter atteinte aux valeurs de la société, de la laïcité, de la neutralité, comme un danger.
Donc elle porte ce foulard et donc elle représenterait,
à ce moment un danger.
Et aussi donc, des informations sont divulguées par des personnes lambda, disons, qui le font, qui ont l'habitude de le faire, on va dire, dont c'est le business, c'est le core business de le faire.
Et ce qui a été dramatique, c'est
que la Sûreté de l'État se nourrisse de ces paroles un peu qui circulent dans les réseaux sociaux et qui font que les réseaux sociaux fonctionnent, le système de buzz,
et donc se nourrissent de ces éléments sans les vérifier,
fassent des rapports.
Ensuite, les informations fuitent de nouveau. Et donc c'est toute une série de dérives qui sont inacceptables sur le plan du droit, de la justice, de la bonne tenue
politique des institutions de notre pays, mais qu'on se permet à l'égard des musulmans.
Et en l'occurrence, c'est Ihsane qui l'a pris
de plein fouet. Et donc ça pose toute une série de questions, notamment sur la question de : est-ce qu'il existe des citoyens de seconde zone, voilà, dont nous sommes et envers lesquels le droit ne se tient plus ?
Et donc on serait dans une espèce de zone de non-droit. Et toute une série de personnes auraient des droits sur nous, c'est-à-dire des accusations, des—
Et cette zone de non-droit
et de régime d'exception en fait par rapport aux communautés musulmanes, pour moi, elle se reflète en fait dans ce que j'appelle le régime de présomption de culpabilité.
C'est-à-dire que normalement, dans un état de droit, tout citoyen bénéficie de la présomption d'innocence jusqu'à la preuve ou à la démonstration évidente de sa culpabilité.
Quand il s'agit d'un citoyen musulman ou d'une citoyenne musulmane, eh bien c'est exactement la logique inverse qui s'impose.
C'est-à-dire qu'on est présenté comme quelqu'un de coupable jusqu'à la preuve finalement de notre innocence.
Et l'affaire d'Ihsane Haouach, quelque part, a établi ça de manière éclatante et aussi comment cette culpabilité, ce phénomène de culpabilité fonctionne, c'est-à-dire que c'est une culpabilité par association.
Il suffirait d'avoir adressé la parole à telle ou telle personne, d'avoir fréquenté tel ou tel lieu, par association, on serait coupable des agissements commis par ailleurs.
Et donc c'est quelque chose d'absolument dangereux, évidemment, parce qu'il n'y a plus aucune balise
digne d'un État qui se revendique un État démocratique, un État de droit, qui vient protéger en fait les citoyens musulmans et les citoyennes musulmanes lorsqu'elles se trouvent dans de telles configurations.
Et ça, c'est vraiment quelque chose de très particulier dans le cas de l'islamophobie et comment la mécanique islamophobe aussi se développe et produit des effets.
Mh. Ce qui est intéressant à voir, c'était la panique, le sentiment de perte de contrôle auquel on a pu assister quand il y a eu donc cette nomination au poste de commissaire au sein de l'Institut pour l'égalité femmes hommes.
Certains ont analysé la séquence non pas à travers le prisme de la, voilà, la fameuse neutralité qui voudrait que on n'affiche pas de signes religieux quand on occupe une fonction publique, mais plutôt en disant que
finalement, voilà, la place dans notre société qui est réservée, en l'occurrence aux femmes qui portent le foulard, c'est obligatoirement une place opprimée, une place qui ne ferait envie à personne.
Donc voilà, les classes populaires, la pauvreté,
ainsi de suite. Et que quand, voilà, quand on affiche, quand on met en avant sous les projecteurs une personne qui a un CV en béton, comme disait Alexander De Croo,
qui est nommée au poste de commissaire au sein du gouvernement fédéral,
certains ont parlé alors d'une forme de panique identitaire et de chasse aux sorcières.
Est-ce que vous partagez cette analyse ?
Oui hein. Oui, le terme chasse aux sorcières n'est absolument pas exagéré. Et c'est d'ailleurs, ça a été souligné par plusieurs personnalités.
C'est la première fois qu'une nomination suscite autant de débats et monte jusqu'à un tel niveau de pouvoir pour être discutée à des places de débats politiques importants en pleine crise sanitaire.
Et donc oui, y a eu chasse aux sorcières. Et maintenant, on va dire, on a un tout petit peu de recul
par rapport à tout ça pour, ben étant donné que finalement, la Sûreté de l'État a dit qu'il y avait rien du tout, etc.
Mais c'est intéressant de voir comment par ce mécanisme, en fait, on tente de décourager toute personne qui ressemblerait à Ihsane Haouach de prétendre à évoluer socialement,
à obtenir des postes de prestige, comme l'a dit Khadija.
Et donc c'est un maintien dans l'infériorité sociale, et de dire : Contentez-vous de ce qu'on vous donne déjà, c'est-à-dire le back-office, voilà les postes dont personne n'a envie, comme vous l'avez dit.
Et c'est cette— On tente de donner, de lancer un message à toutes les autres. C'est : Vous voulez subir la même chose ?
Eh bien, tentez l'expérience. Sinon, si vous voulez pas subir tout ça, et je pense que de notre côté aussi, personne n'a envie Ihsane dans tout ce qu'elle a subi.
Et donc voilà, il y a toute une série de personnes qui vont se poser des questions. C'est aussi des choses auxquelles on est confronté tous les jours.
C'est des jeunes filles, des jeunes femmes qui portent un foulard et qui posent la question du choix d'études ou du choix professionnel.
Est-ce que si je fais telles études, je serai acceptée avec mon foulard, oui ou non ? Est-ce que si je fais des études, j'aurai accès à telle profession ou non ?
Et c'est dramatique au XXIᵉ siècle,
que des femmes se posent ce type de questions avec un sentiment d'être obligées de laisser une partie de leur identité, celle en l'occurrence qui est pointée du doigt par
toute, voilà, toute cette catégorie de politiciens qui ciblent ces femmes, parce qu'elles estiment être en danger d'une certaine manière.
Et donc oui, 'fin, y a cette question de criminalisation tout simplement d'un fait, c'est celui qu'une partie de la population est musulmane pratiquante et qu'on veut pas d'elle dans la société.
Oui. Moi, ce que
ce que m'évoque également cette question-là, c'est toute la problématique en fait de la représentation et des limites des politiques de représentation
à l'égard des populations qu'on considère comme minorisées ou,
ou des minorités dites ethniques, raciales, je dirais plutôt.
Effectivement, donc il y a cette volonté affichée de la part des différents acteurs politiques, et notamment dans le champ progressiste, de lutter contre les discriminations, de lutter contre le racisme.
Et souvent la stratégie qui est prônée pour le faire, c'est d'avoir recours à l'une ou l'autre figure symbolique que l'on va
mettre à tel ou tel poste, mais sans garantir nécessairement tous les garde-fous autour de cette nomination ou de cette,
de d'un recrutement particulier.
Donc ça va se limiter en fait à une position purement symbolique. Et moi, ce qui m'a frappée aussi dans la nomination, par exemple, d'Ihsane Haouach, c'est que,
pour la nommer, donc le parti Écolo qui procède à cette nomination, a l'air de considérer que,
ou en tout cas de faire abstraction du fait qu'une femme qui porte le foulard ne susciterait en fait à ce poste-là,
aucune réaction.
Or, on sait qu'on est dans une société qui est structurellement islamophobe, qui est structurellement raciste et qui est hostile à des signes visibles d'appartenance à l'islam comme le port du foulard.
Et donc y a eu, enfin, ça a donné l'impression en fait qu'il n'y a eu aucune anticipation des attaques qui auraient
pu advenir à l'égard et à l'endroit d'Ihsane Haouach et que finalement, Ihsane Haouach s'est retrouvée un petit peu seule aux prises avec ce tir croisé d'attaques qui venaient vers elle,
et sans finalement de soutien affiché ou de soutien avéré dans cette tempête.
Et donc ça, c'est quelque chose quand même,
à mon sens aussi, de problématique, c'est-à-dire que de la part d'autorités politiques, d'autorités publiques, il ne suffit pas,
à mon sens, lorsque l'on a envie de promouvoir, parce que je pense que la démarche, c'était— elle était symbolique, elle était de promouvoir une femme voilée pour montrer, voilà,
symboliquement que c'était possible d'accéder à un tel poste de prestige qui n'est pas un poste de pouvoir en tant que tel, mais qui est un poste de prestige étant nommé par le gouvernement fédéral.
Et donc y avait une volonté symbolique en la matière. Or,
le parti ne se donne pas les moyens d'aller jusqu'au bout de la démarche et de finalement garantir en fait les conditions qui vont sécuriser la place et la fonction d'Ihsane Haouach une fois qu'elle est nommée.
Et ça, c'est problématique aussi. Donc il ne suffit pas— enfin, ça montre que les intentions, parfois aussi bonnes soient-elles, ne suffisent pas et que parfois l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions aussi.
Oui, oui. Je pense effectivement avoir compris qu'après l'interview d'Ihsane Haouach dans Le Soir, la décision a été prise de surtout ne plus trop en parler publiquement et voilà, de plutôt essayer de se faire oublier.
Y compris donc ne plus en parler publiquement pour la défendre et de montrer qu'il n'y avait absolument aucun problème. Donc autrement dit, une certaine passivité.
Et voilà, comme vous dites, Écolo ne s'est pas vraiment donné les moyens de monter au front pour la défendre. Et là, il faut peut-être aussi rappeler que voilà, en Belgique, un gouvernement, un gouvernement fédéral, c'est très fragile.
Donc essayer d'enterrer les conflits et de tourner la page, selon moi, c'est une stratégie qui peut se comprendre.
Mais donc oui, cette passivité est en partie, voilà, ce qui a amené Ihsane Haouach à démissionner. Une idée récurrente qui entoure toutes ces questions, sont les questions de genre.
Est-ce que vous avez pu sentir tout au long de cette séquence un soutien de la part des féministes de manière générale, quelles qu'elles soient ?
Ou bien est-ce que, en fait, la sororité s'arrête finalement dès qu'on parle des femmes musulmanes ?
Bah, je pense que ce— enfin, je vais commencer, puis on pourra continuer à échanger avec Kaoutar là-dessus.
Mais cette question de la sororité, effectivement, qui est une notion,
enfin centrale dans les discours féministes, qui est une notion politique, à mon sens, qui n'est pas quelque chose de naturel.
C'est pas parce que l'on est femme que l'on est forcément solidaire, en fait, d'une autre femme. C'est— la sororité, elle se construit politiquement.
Et force est de constater, bon, ici, on est dans la séquence d'Ihsane Haouach, mais de manière beaucoup plus, enfin sur le temps long, en fait, c'est des discriminations que subissent
les femmes musulmanes ici en Belgique.
Donc, on a eu différentes séquences hein, ne fut-ce que sur la dernière année, avec, enfin sur l'interdiction d'avoir accès,
à l'enseignement supérieur, les discriminations en matière donc d'accès à l'emploi, d'embauche, etc.
Je ne dirais pas qu'il n'y a pas de soutien féministe de manière générale. Y en a de,
y en a certainement de la part de certaines franges, en tout cas, des actrices féministes, mais ce n'est pas quelque chose, je pense notamment à Vie féminine,
qui a pu parfois prendre position, voilà, en faveur des femmes musulmanes et plus spécifiquement des femmes musulmanes qui portent le foulard,
mais ce n'est pas quelque chose, voilà, qui est majoritairement, c'est pas une position majoritaire au sein du mouvement féministe, du mouvement féministe blanc.
Et donc, on en revient à cette question de la sororité qui,
effectivement, là, on voit que c'est quelque chose qui doit être construit politiquement et qui
ne va pas de soi, dès lors que l'on est une femme musulmane qui décide d'afficher son islamité publiquement par des attributs spécifiques.
Et donc ça, c'est une question beaucoup plus générique en fait, de se dire finalement le féminisme blanc, puis le white feminism tel qu'on le définit, est-ce que c'est un phénomène universel ?
Est-ce que le féminisme, par sa vocation originelle,
vise à défendre les intérêts de l'ensemble des femmes, quelles qu'elles soient, quel que soit leur milieu social d'origine, quelle que soit leur race, quelle que soit leur appartenance religieuse ?
Ou est-ce que c'est plutôt un phénomène qui est circonscrit dans des conditions politiques et historiques qui lui sont propres ?
Et force est de constater que c'est plutôt la deuxième option qui se révèle exacte. C'est-à-dire que
le féminisme n'a pas, et c'est souvent là un peu le péché que l'on prête au féminisme, 'fin l'intention en tout cas que l'on prête au féminisme d'avoir une prétention universelle, universaliste.
Or, dans les faits, le féminisme s'est construit à partir d'un contexte tout à fait particulier, 'fin, qui justifiait effectivement l'existence de ce mouvement politique du féminisme, mais qui s'est construit
historiquement, en tout cas, je parle de la Belgique, mais c'est le cas également d'autres pays, notamment en France, d'autres pays européens, qui s'est construit historiquement dans une certaine cécité par rapport
au fait, au fait colonial, au fait impérial, impérialiste, puisque le phénomène du féminisme a pris son essor au moment où la colonisation était encore,
'fin était en plein développement, donc au début, par exemple, du XXᵉ siècle.
Et donc c'est un phénomène qui n'a pas du tout, en fait, pris en considération la question,
des femmes dans les colonies, dans les colonies belges, par exemple,
non seulement qui s'est construit dans cette relative cécité, mais qui, en plus, à certains moments, a pris même fait et cause pour le fait colonial et l'impérialisme,
des grandes métropoles européennes et de la métropole belge en particulier.
Je pense notamment à l'Union des femmes
coloniales en Belgique, qui était une organisation de féministes qui a été fondée dans les années 1920
et qui avait donc pour but d'améliorer les conditions de vie des femmes belges au sein de la colonie et donc au sein du Congo plus spécifiquement.
Mais en même temps, elles avaient, elles se donnaient pour mission, en fait, une mission civilisatrice à l'égard des femmes indigènes.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y avait cette prétention de supériorité, en fait, morale et civilisationnelle qui était proprement revendiquée par ces féministes-là.
Et donc, par ce fait-là, on voit qu'il y a une,
un parti pris en faveur du projet colonial et du projet impérialiste, puisque cette question de la mission civilisatrice, elle est au cœur, effectivement, du projet colonial.
Et donc le féminisme n'est pas exempt de colonialité. Il s'est construit dans une consubstantialité, en fait, avec le projet colonial.
Il est empreint de colonialité et il est encore empreint de colonialité à l'heure d'aujourd'hui. Et notamment, ça se traduit à l'heure actuelle, de manière tout à fait évidente,
par une des formes de désolidarisation à l'égard des femmes, des femmes musulmanes et notamment des femmes,
musulmanes qui portent le foulard, qui sont vues effectivement comme des femmes qui soit sont soumises, donc qui sont sous l'oppression.
Donc, on ne les considère pas en fait comme des,
comme des êtres adultes à part entière, capables d'opérer un choix,
en toute conscience et en toute connaissance de cause, mais plutôt comme des mineurs qui seraient sous l'emprise d'un patriarcat et qui seraient incapables, du coup, d'opposer une résistance à ce patriarcat.
Ça, c'est dans le versant civilisationnel. Et puis, de plus en plus aussi, ce à quoi on... le glissement auquel on assiste
par rapport aux femmes qui portent le foulard, c'est qu'elles sont de plus en plus vues également comme un cheval de Troie de l'islamisme.
Et donc ça, c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est également de plus en plus présent dans les discours hostiles aux femmes qui portent le foulard.
Donc non seulement il y a ce versant civilisationnel, mais il y a également le versant de la menace sécuritaire que représenteraient les femmes musulmanes,
par le simple fait que voilà, elles adhéraient à un projet qui serait par essence un projet,
hostile à l'Occident, qui serait,
hostile aux valeurs,
de l'Occident, aux valeurs de liberté, aux valeurs d'émancipation et qui ferait peser une menace sur la sécurité,
publique parce qu'elles seraient intrinsèquement, par essence, reliées à des réseaux qui seraient dangereux.
Donc ça, c'est un discours, on va fêter, ben la semaine prochaine, le triste anniversaire des attentats du 11 septembre.
Ce discours-là, il a pris vraiment de l'envergure ces vingt dernières années. Donc voilà. Et c'est le gli— c'est tout le glissement
dans l'islamophob— dans l'histoire contemporaine de l'islamophobie entre,
la pratique de l'islam, puisque le port du foulard, voilà, peut être, c'est un attribut qui peut être relié simplement à une pratique,
tout à fait commune, en fait, de l'islam, à quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de l'islamisme.
Et donc ce glissement entre,
qui est tout à fait dangereux, entre finalement les attributs des musulmans lambda et les attributs de terroristes djihadistes, islamistes, etc.,
qui seraient en fait des individus qui feraient peser une menace sur la sécurité de l'État.
Et donc c'est pas un hasard finalement si dans le cas de l'affaire Ihsane Haouach, on en vient à cette question des Frères musulmans in fine.
C'est qu'on voit un peu tout le cheminement qu'il y a,
qu'il y a derrière. On est parti de la question de la neutralité et on en arrive finalement à une question qui n'a plus rien à voir en fait avec la neutralité de l'État,
qui est celle de la menace sur la sûreté de l'État, puisqu'il y a une confusion qui est pour moi pas de l'ordre de la dérive, puisqu'une dérive, c'est quelque chose qu'on ne maîtrise pas.
Pour moi, c'est un phénomène qui est maîtrisé puisqu'il y a véritablement des acteurs aussi qui nourrissent hein tout ça.
On a parlé du rôle des médias. Il y a des officines comme l'Observatoire des fondamentalismes qui se sont données pour mission, depuis un certain temps en Belgique, en Belgique francophone notamment,
de cibler des organisations qui ont une coloration musulmane ou des individualités de confession musulmane et d'en faire des objets de menace en tant que tels, de les construire en objets de menace.
Et donc voilà. Donc c'est un processus qui est complètement maîtrisé, qui a ses acteurs, qui a ses logiques, et ses procédés qui lui sont propres.
Et c'est ça véritablement qui est problématique dans toute cette affaire.
Mh. Donc y a une confusion, un rapprochement qui est systématiquement fait entre le terrorisme islamiste et la pratique musulmane de manière générale.
Y a aussi dans l'imaginaire collectif occidental l'idée que l'islam serait, voilà,
patriarcal par essence et que les musulmans, et en particulier les femmes, sont des personnes qu'il faut émanciper un peu, voilà, en quelque sorte, émanciper de force.
Et voilà, oui, c'est ce que vous disiez sur le féminisme colonial du XXe siècle. Est-ce que, si je pose la question maintenant à Kaoutar, est-ce que vous percevez cette idée au jour le jour que l'islam serait patriarcal par essence ?
Et qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Bah oui, et c'est ce que soulignait Khadija, c'est-à-dire qu'on nous reproche à nous d'avoir fait un choix, avec l'idée que ce choix est imposé par les hommes.
Mais cette imposition, elle est totalement imaginée par ceux qui accusent. Y a même des études justement qui ont été faites,
à ce sujet et qui démontrent que dans la majorité des cas, l'écrasante majorité des cas, ce foulard est porté de manière autonome, choisie.
Et donc si les détracteurs du port du foulard veulent maintenir cette idée, eh bien, ils vont créer donc de toutes pièces, cette— et nourrir les imaginaires pour entretenir cette idée.
Ça se fait de différentes manières. On va aller,
sur le terrain sociologique, sur le terrain théologique, sur le terrain politique, et tout ça pour arriver à la conclusion que, non, in fine, ces femmes qui portent le foulard, en fait, elles vous mentent.
La réalité, c'est nous qui la connaissons. Nous la connaissons pour elle-même et nous la connaissons pour la société.
Et ça s'inscrit donc dans ce processus de, voilà, quand une femme porte un foulard, d'emblée, c'est qu'elle est soumise, ou alors si elle est consciente, c'est qu'elle est un étendard politique.
Et donc en fait, peu importe la posture réelle, notre posture réelle, on va toujours se retrouver dans des espèces de fantasmes, d'imaginaires qui vont faire de nous des ennemis intérieurs à combattre.
Évidemment, dans la communauté musulmane, mais ça aussi, c'est historique. C'est— l'homme musulman, c'est un danger pour la société occidentale.
Même quand on remonte dans les écrits, au XIIe siècle, c'est déjà le cas. Bah, le monde musulman se trouve aux portes de l'Occident, donc forcément.
et les comparaisons entre, voilà, les,
les hommes musulmans, présentés dans les tableaux orientalistes comme étant forcément des conquérants, des barbares, des vendeurs de femmes esclaves dans les marchés.
Et tout ça, c'est des— toutes ces images, on va dire, sont issues des imaginaires. C'était le cas y a deux siècles, c'était le cas y a huit siècles, c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui.
Et donc, c'est— juste la société a changé. Aujourd'hui, bah, nous musulmanes vivons dans la société et on se retrouve confrontées à ces imaginaires, à ces fantasmes.
Et bah, disons que ça— culturellement, ça a une explication. Mais de nouveau, sur le plan de la dignité, de la moralité, ce sont des mensonges.
Ce qu'on va imaginer au sujet d'Ihsane Haouach, c'est— ce n'est pas exceptionnel, c'est des choses qui reviennent constamment et, 'fin, on a l'habitude de ces accusations.
Et voilà, ces accusations s'inscrivent dans une continuité culturelle, dans une tradition de construction de l'ennemi intérieur, par la criminalisation de l'étranger de manière générale et des musulmans en particulier.
On évoquait tout à l'heure la question du féminisme musulman par opposition au féminisme colonial. J'aimerais vous poser la question
: comment est-ce que ces initiatives-là sont reçues au sein de la communauté musulmane, par les hommes ?
Si vous permettez, j'aimerais juste profiter de votre question pour revenir un petit peu sur la discussion que vous avez eue il y a quelques minutes, justement, sur le féminisme, white feminism.
Oui.
En fait, concrètement, sur le terrain, oui, y a des alliés,
Parmi les féministes blanches. Mais de manière plus pragmatique, comment ça se passe ? C'est qu'en fait, le monde des féministes mainstream, white feminists, discutent de notre légitimité.
Et entre-temps, nous, nous devons avancer sur la lutte pour notre dignité. Et c'est en cela que, on va dire,
avancent de manière parallèle les femmes musulmanes et les féministes blanches mainstream.
Mais sinon, le combat des femmes blanches féministes, ben comme l'a précisé Khadija, il s'inscrit dans un contexte et il est légitime par rapport à ce contexte. De même que
pour nous-mêmes qui nous retrouvons dans ce contexte, on a énormément de points de croisement, c'est-à-dire que quand on se retrouve au travail, eh bien on subit la même chose que les femmes blanches, c'est-à-dire,
on n'a pas le même salaire que les hommes, le plafond de verre, les problèmes de promotion, les problèmes que subissent les femmes enceintes, etc.
Ça, c'est des problèmes qu'on connaît aussi.
On n'a pas de particularité par rapport à toutes ces questions-là. La question qui vient par après
et qui va, on va dire, segmenter entre les deux, c'est quand les white feminists vont se poser la question de : est-ce que les femmes musulmanes sont légitimes dans leurs revendications propres,
dans les revendications qui les concernent elles-mêmes ?
Est-ce que le soin de ces femmes peut exister dans le monde féministe ou pas ? Et donc ça, c'est des questions qui animent le monde des white feminists, mais bon pour être très franc, on,
on n'est pas souvent invité à discuter avec elles sur ces sujets.
Mais disons, les questions nous sont rapportées par celles d'entre elles qui, justement, voudraient créer plus de jonctions, plus de ponts, qui estiment que le white féminisme se retrouverait renforcé
si les femmes musulmanes intégraient ces mouvements pour constituer une force politique plus importante, etc.
Mais entre-temps, on n'a pas le choix que d'avancer sur notre terrain, sur ce qui constitue notre identité, nos propres droits, en tant que femmes particulières.
Oui, pourquoi pas ? Et donc c'est parce que vous venez de poser la question en disant l'opposition féminisme musulman au white féminisme.
Je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
un positionnement par opposition au white féminisme. C'est juste que l'avancement d'un groupe et de l'autre ne se fait pas de la même manière parce que les priorités ne sont pas les mêmes,
parce que l'organisation sociopolitique et justement la constitution des forces politiques et
et l'établissement des politiques d'avancement dans les rapports de force n'est pas le même et n'a pas les mêmes priorités. Donc ça, ça-
Oui, je me permets juste de revenir sur ce que vous disiez, le fait que ce n'est pas une opposition entre féminisme blanc et féminisme musulman.
En fait, j'en arrivais à présenter les choses de cette manière parce qu'en fait, j'ai pu voir
des vidéos de ce collectif qui s'appelle Imazi Ren, où une personne partageait son témoignage en disant que quand on se présente à elle en disant
: moi, je suis féministe, son premier réflexe, auparavant,
ce n'était plus le cas au moment où elle a fait la vidéo, mais auparavant, ça avait pu être quelque chose comme : mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc occidental ? Et
elle expliquait aussi que c'était impossible pour elle de dire : moi, je suis féministe, sans immédiatement rajouter le mot décolonial ou musulmane derrière, parce que voilà, il y a ce passif historique, ce féminisme blanc qui a été
et qui est encore oppresseur des femmes musulmanes.
Donc voilà, je précise juste que c'est pour cette raison que j'avais présenté les choses de cette manière-là.
Oui, mais donc il faut juste préciser que si opposition il y a, effectivement hein, j'ai moi-même souligné qu'il y avait plusieurs points, disons, de rupture.
En fait, si opposition il y a, ce n'est pas dans le chef des musulmanes que de dire : nous nous opposons aux féministes blanches par principe.
C'est justement parce qu'il y a un passif, parce que voilà, quand on se rend compte qu'on se pose la question de est-ce que oui ou non, nous sommes des femmes ?
Enfin, ça rappelle des mauvais souvenirs de quand, voilà, il y a quelques siècles, on se posait la question de : est-ce que les femmes ont une âme ou pas ?
Eh bien, voilà, maintenant, on se pose la question de est-ce que nous sommes légitimes en tant que femmes ou pas de nous exprimer avec des revendications qui concernent les femmes musulmanes ?
Eh bien, voilà, c'est ce qui aboutit, disons, à une bifurcation. Mais donc le féminisme musulman s'est constitué à partir de ses particularités et pas forcément par rapport au white féminisme, au féminisme blanc.
C'est-à-dire que le féminisme blanc a fait son chemin. Les femmes musulmanes, à un moment donné, estiment que c'est un terrain à prospecter.
Elles y vont. Il y a beaucoup de clash, beaucoup de points de rupture, des problèmes. Et puis finalement, il y a bifurcation.
Et donc je sais pas, il faudrait voir avec les sociologues ou les politologues qui ont vraiment étudié le phénomène.
Et y en a. Mais voilà. En tout cas, dans la manière dont on présente les choses, il faut
garder en tête que les femmes musulmanes ont des revendications qui les concernent, et elles doivent être elles-mêmes aussi, comment on va dire ?
Avoir en main la manière dont elles vont constituer l'organisation politique de leur militance. Parce qu'un problème aussi qu'il y a avec le white féminisme, c'est qu'on nous impose un agenda politique,
mais qui nous concerne pas avec nos particularités sociales, politiques, culturelles.
Et donc on a le droit aussi de se dire : ben voilà, sur tel point, nous, notre priorité, elle est plus à tel niveau.
Vraiment, pour être concrète hein. Quand on a des discussions, par exemple, parce qu'y a, voilà, y a des initiatives qui regroupent des féministes de manière plus large, sur des questions.
Et des fois, on arrive à discuter sur l'évolution du statut professionnel des femmes, je veux dire de manière très pointue et légitime.
Mais moi, à ce moment-là, je suis obligée de rappeler que pour moi, le problème, c'est l'accès à l'emploi. Avant d'être sur des statuts particuliers, le droit au congé,
le droit à certaines formes de reconnaissance, des maladies professionnelles, des choses comme ça. En fait,
voilà, la réalité fait que moi, je n'ai pas le luxe de déjà m'exprimer sur ces sujets. Moi, mon--
J'en suis encore à juste réclamer le droit d'accès à l'enseignement et le droit d'accès à l'emploi pour toutes les femmes, en ce compris celles qui portent un foulard. Voilà.
Moi, j'évoquais tout à l'heure la question des intérêts. Donc
le féminisme, comme tout mouvement sociopolitique, s'ancre
dans un contexte et défend des intérêts particuliers qui sont effectivement ceux de catégories de femmes particulières, qui sont en l'occurrence ici les femmes blanches.
Considérer d'office, en fait, comme vous avez tendance à le présenter, que tout combat de femmes, notamment de femmes musulmanes, est un combat féministe, pour moi, ça me pose question.
C'est pas forcément le cas. Moi, je peux, ou une autre ou telle autre, me battre pour la dignité, l'émancipation de femmes sans pour autant me définir comme féministe.
Une autre se définira comme féministe. Ça, c'est une question de perspective, de choix, de choix politique.
Mais je pense que ce serait une erreur. Et ça, on en reviendrait justement à la question de cette prééminence un peu coloniale et de colonialité du féminisme, de se considérer comme universel.
Or, ce n'est pas le cas. On peut très bien être une femme non-blanche, comme une femme blanche d'ailleurs, et lutter pour l'émancipation, les droits, la dignité, sans nécessairement se définir comme,
comme féministe.
Et tout simplement parce qu'en tant que femme non-blanche, en tant que femme musulmane plus spécifiquement, on vit une oppression qui est tout à fait particulière.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a évidemment notre condition de femme, mais il y a notre condition de femme musulmane, c'est-à-dire notre appartenance de race, notre appartenance religieuse, qui fait que, eh bien, nos intérêts sont divergents.
C'est pas juste une question de priorité à mon sens, c'est une question d'intérêt particulier à un moment donné. De manière plus concrète, ben moi, par exemple,
je vais, en tant que femme, me préoccuper, et en tant que mère, me préoccuper de savoir quand est-ce que mon fils va avoir sa première confrontation avec la police, puisque c'est un enfant, voilà, qui est plutôt typé, qui...
Voilà, c'est plutôt ce type de questionnement-là aussi qui va m'animer,
et qui ne va pas animer une femme blanche parce qu'on sait très bien que la question des violences policières, elle touche de manière très spécifique les jeunes hommes arabes, noirs, musulmans dans nos sociétés.
Et donc voilà, donc ça en fait une question qui est particulière, qui est particulière à moi en tant que femme, en tant que mère musulmane, enfin voilà, arabe, dans cette société-là.
Et la deuxième particularité aussi, quand je dis que je suis une femme musulmane, c'est que je n'ai pas le luxe de n'agir que pour mes intérêts propres de femme.
C'est-à-dire que notre condition de femme musulmane, elle est aussi spécifique dans la mesure où, historiquement, la mission civilisatrice, elle est passée par les femmes, et par les femmes musulmanes plus spécifiquement.
On peut se rappeler les écrits de Fanon sur
sur le dévoilement des femmes en Algérie, des cérémonies donc qui étaient dédiées en fait publiquement,
qui étaient organisées par des généraux français pour dévoiler les femmes musulmanes par leurs épouses, donc sur la place publique.
Et donc c'était une manière non seulement de prendre possession en fait du corps des femmes, mais également de les arracher symboliquement à leurs familles, à leurs communautés, à leurs communautés d'origine.
Et donc y avait toute une ambition, en fait, de déstructurer les noyaux familiaux, de déstructurer les communautés dans lesquelles les femmes musulmanes vivaient, auxquelles elles appartenaient.
Et donc, je crois que cette dimension-là, elle est tout à fait spécifique dans notre cas, c'est que notre combat, il est intimement lié,
et il y a une dimension tout à fait particulière qui est celle de nos familles et de nos communautés et de nos hommes aussi, finalement, qui sont en fait, eux aussi,
touchés par l'islamophobie, mais d'une autre manière, et qui sont également touchés par des formes particulières du patriarcat dominant, puisque vous posiez la question du patriarcat,
au sein des communautés musulmanes.
Mais je pense qu'avant de poser cette question-là,
qui est une question effectivement qui peut se poser, hein, donc, et qu'il ne faut pas nier, mais il revient alors aux femmes musulmanes d'y apporter une réponse et à personne d'autre
Mais si on en revient à cette question du patriarcat musulman,
il existe dans, et il coexiste dans une relation un peu
dialectique avec un patriarcat qui s'impose à lui en fait, qui est le patriarcat blanc, qui est dominant.
C'est-à-dire que ce patriarcat, bien évidemment, il a des
des répercussions sur les femmes musulmanes, on le voit, beh, par rapport aux femmes musulmanes qui portent le foulard, par exemple, dans leur accès à l'emploi, à l'enseignement, etc.
Mais il a également des répercussions matérielles extrêmement fortes sur les hommes musulmans, puisque eux aussi sont victimes de discrimination dans un autre,
cadre et dans une autre mesure, mais ils sont également et surtout victimes en fait de la répression d'État qui leur est tout à fait-- qui est un phénomène qui est tout à fait spécifique, qui leur est tout à fait,
qui leur est tout à fait particulier.
Donc la répression dont sont victimes les hommes non blancs,
les hommes blancs,
y sont tout à fait étrangers. Et donc, de la même manière que l'on commence petit à petit à considérer que les intérêts des femmes blanches et des femmes non blanches ne sont pas exactement les mêmes à travers la question de l'intersectionnalité,
beh, il faut avancer également dans le sens de considérer que le patriarcat n'est pas un patriarcat universel.
Comme de la même façon qu'il n'y a pas de féminisme universel, il n'y a pas de patriarcat universel. C'est-à-dire que les hommes n'occupent pas la même,
la même place et la même fonction de pouvoir et d'autorité selon qu'ils soient blancs ou non blancs dans nos sociétés libérales occidentales
aujourd'hui, tout simplement parce que les hommes non blancs subissent des formes tout à fait particulières d'exclusion socio-économique, mais aussi des formes tout à fait particulières de répression d'État.
Et on l'a vu de manière flagrante aussi après les attentats de Paris et de Bruxelles avec l'instauration des dispositifs qui ont été mis en place.
Et vous parliez de chasse aux sorcières, beh, effectivement, la chasse aux sorcières, là, elle a été
vraiment institutionnalisée dans le cadre du plan Canal, par exemple, avec plus de 95 000 adresses
qui ont été contrôlées, donc des contrôles domiciliaires, un nombre invraisemblable de
perquisitions dans des familles musulmanes, donc des noyaux familiaux qui ont été complètement déstructurés par ces perquisitions, des associations
musulmanes, des mosquées, etc.
Et donc voilà. Donc y a une volonté aussi d'inscrire un mode de gouvernementalité qui est spécifique aux communautés musulmanes et qui a des répercussions à la fois sur les hommes, à la fois sur les femmes.
Et donc l'islamophobie, finalement, elle produit des effets genrés selon que l'on soit femme, selon que l'on soit homme.
Et donc la condition de femme musulmane, elle est également particulière en ce sens-là, c'est qu'on est contrainte finalement, par nécessité, de tenir compte en fait de tout cet écosystème.
Et c'est peut-être la particularité qui nous distingue des féministes
blanches ou des femmes blanches de manière plus générale, c'est qu'on n'a pas
le luxe d'avancer uniquement pour nos intérêts de femmes particuliers, mais que notre condition racialisée fait qu'on a une dimension beaucoup plus large qui est la nôtre en fait.
Donc nos intérêts vont au-delà de notre individualité, de notre personne individuelle.
Mh. Alors, vous parliez, Khadija, des effets de l'islamophobie sur les hommes et les femmes musulmanes. On évoquait la question du patriarcat au sein de la communauté musulmane il y a un instant.
Une analyse que j'ai pu entendre et que je trouvais très intéressante à explorer aujourd'hui avec vous, c'est l'idée que l'islamophobie contribue justement à maintenir en place le patriarcat au sein, voilà, de la communauté musulmane.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette idée ?
Oui, mais votre question établit le postulat suivant lequel il y a forcément un patriarcat dans la communauté musulmane.
Et c'est l'idée qu'essayait de déconstruire Khadija dans l'intervention juste avant. C'est qu'en fait,
la question patriarcale
de la relation entre les, une communauté de femmes et leurs hommes, c'est-à-dire leurs époux, leurs papas, leurs fils, est différente en fonction des communautés, en fonction des contextes, en fonction des époques.
Et donc il n'y a pas de patriarcat universel et que ce qui peut être considéré comme étant patriarcal au sens sociologique de
la domination masculine absolue,
telle que l'ont connue les femmes occidentales dans la société occidentale et qui a fait que le féminisme a émergé de cette manière-là plus précisément,
n'est pas forcément le même que celui du patriarcat tel qu'il est présent dans la communauté musulmane.
Mais cela dit, bon, je comprends le fond de votre question. Et, et bah forcément, quand on empêche des femmes d'accéder à l'émancipation financière, l'émancipation,
voilà, par l'éducation, etc., bah forcément, on alimente d'une manière ou d'une autre la,
la toute-puissance ou la mainmise des hommes sur les femmes puisqu'elles deviennent forcément dépendantes des hommes.
Et donc elles deviennent dépendantes des hommes. Donc je ne dis pas par là que la dépendance est forcément signe de patriarcat et de domination et de violence, etc.
C'est que, bah oui, il ne faut pas s'étonner que quand on empêche des femmes d'accéder à l'autonomie, tout simplement, bah forcément, elles sont dépendantes d'hommes, de leur entourage. Et
Aussi nous sur le terrain, on voit des particularités qui font que--
disons que ces mêmes politiciens qui reprochent aux femmes musulmanes d'être dans des états de soumission en portant le foulard, on les voit par exemple
avoir des relations avec des organes qui sont ultra patriarcaux au sens occidental du terme, c'est le cas de le dire, de les entretenir, de les financer, de, voilà.
Je prends par exemple l'exécutif des musulmans avec lesquels l'État a d'excellentes relations, parce que l'État s'ingère dans cet organe et en fait un peu ce qu'il veut avec les bonhommes qui sont là, on va dire.
Mais voilà, à ce moment-là, l'État s'accommode très bien, les politiciens s'accommodent très bien du patriarcat-
Est-ce que vous pouvez présenter un petit peu l'exécutif des musulmans pour celles et ceux qui ne savent pas ce que c'est ?
Bah écoutez, c'est une espèce d'organe représentatif des musulmans en Belgique. Donc il est censé représenter les musulmans en Belgique.
Sauf que finalement, in fine, cet organe ne représente que très peu les musulmans et les musulmans de manière générale se désaffilient de cet organe.
Et ce qu'on constate, c'est que les personnes qui sont placées dans cet organe,
le sont par les politiciens. 'Fin pire encore, le sont suivant un accord entre les politiciens belges et les politiciens étrangers dont sont originaires les musulmans de Belgique.
Et voilà. Donc on peut voir, hein, quel type de personnes occupent ces fonctions, d'où est-ce qu'elles viennent, avec les réunions, etc.
On voit quels intérêts elles nourrissent. Et voilà. Et l'histoire fait qu'y a un passif, justement, depuis que cet organe existe, y a un passif
qui fait qu'on voit très bien comment les politiciens essayent de maintenir cet organe absolument pour avoir la main sur la communauté musulmane.
Et à ce moment-là, le patriarcat ne les dérange absolument pas, aux politiciens.
Et justement, voilà, ils vont utiliser le patriarcat existant dominateur dans la communauté musulmane pour arriver à leurs fins politiques auxquelles ils n'y arrivent pas avec le droit qui permettrait l'égalité
entre tous, on va dire.
On va dire ça comme ça. Donc voilà, la question du patriarcat des hommes qui sont dans l'abus de l'autorité envers les femmes, très sincèrement, les femmes musulmanes sont tellement dans un--
J'veux dire, avec tout ce qu'elles vivent, c'est une question qui les concerne et qu'elles sont en capacité de pouvoir résoudre dès lors qu'elles ont les capacités et la possibilité de le faire.
Maintenant, elles doivent faire des priorités. C'est le patriarcat dominant,
d'État avec l'islamophobie organisée, ou le problème avec le patriarcat interne qui est lui-même façonné et nourri par le patriarcat dominant.
Et c'est-- ça rejoint la question que vous avez posée.
Tout à fait. Merci beaucoup. On approche tout doucement de la fin de cet épisode. Si je devais vous demander à toutes les deux un mot pour conclure, un message que vous aimeriez faire passer
à celles et ceux qui nous écoutent et qui, voilà, seraient curieuses de mieux comprendre les causes que vous défendez.
Bah écoutez, on a commencé cet entretien avec la question de savoir comment ou qu'est-ce qui justifie un petit peu notre engagement.
Moi, je terminerai peut-être, du coup, l'entretien par donner un mot d'explication sur une carte blanche que j'ai rédigée juste après, justement, l'affaire Ihsane Haouach,
sur quel est-- qu'est-ce qui a justifié que je prenne la parole à ce moment-là et dans ce contexte-là spécifique.
Et sans doute que ça va faire aussi écho à une série de choses que nous avons discutées durant cette heure. Eh bien, pour moi, c'était la nécessité de briser l'effet de sidération qui est produit auprès des populations musulmanes
par ce type d'accusation, notamment l'accusation d'affiliation aux Frères, aux Frères musulmans.
Alors, on sait,
dans le contexte qui est le nôtre depuis un certain nombre d'années, que cette accusation de terrorisme, cette accusation d'islamisme radical, de djihadisme, 'fin tous les mots en,
en isme, finalement, qui traduisent un peu cette idée d'altérité radicale dangereuse accolée
à l'islam, c'est l'une des accusations les plus infamantes de notre époque
contemporaine.
Et dans la conclusion de
de ma carte blanche, finalement, je prends un peu le contrepied de l'injonction tacite qui nous est faite en tant que musulmans, cette injonction étant celle du not in my name, avec l'idée qui est un peu sous-jacente chaque fois qu'il y a
un acte de terrorisme qui est posé par un musulman quelque part, de devoir en fait s'en désolidariser en tant que musulman.
Et ça, c'est vraiment une spécificité que l'on retrouve qu'à l'égard des musulmans. Je ne vois jamais cette injonction apparaître à l'égard d'autres communautés ou lorsqu'il y a un déséquilibré,
d'ailleurs qu'on présente toujours comme un déséquilibré, non pas comme un terroriste,
d'une autre appartenance que d'origine arabo-musulmane.
Et donc, il y a cette volonté pour-- et cette nécessité politique pour moi de me défaire en fait de cette injonction qui est un piège,
qui ne sert qu'à alimenter en fait toute une série de fantasmes autour de groupuscules qui sont présentés comme des groupuscules obscurs,
dont on ne connaît pas très bien les motivations.
Et les Frères musulmans remplissent cette, je veux dire, cette fonction-là, ici, en Belgique notamment. Et ça ne sert finalement qu'à renforcer un imaginaire qui est hostile aux musulmans et à renforcer l'islamophobie.
Et moi, je trouve nécessaire à un moment donné de ne plus devoir en fait se justifier, non seulement de ne plus devoir se désolidariser, mais de ne plus devoir se justifier par rapport à des appartenances.
Et parce qu'elles, finalement, elles ne traduisent en fait que des imaginaires malades. Et ces imaginaires malades doivent se réformer d'eux-mêmes.
Ce n'est pas à moi à faire ce travail-là à leur place, parce que quelque part, je leur donnerais en fait,
Une légitimité
...une légitimité à s'exprimer. Or, ce n'est pas du tout le cas. Et d'ailleurs, quelles que soient les justifications que l'on peut donner,
je veux dire, ce type d'accusation persiste en général dans le temps.
On le voit, c'est pas la première fois hein qu'une personnalité musulmane est accusée de proximité avec ces fameux Frères musulmans dont
personne ne connaît finalement exactement les contours et l'organisation ici en Belgique. Mais
mais voilà, c'est-- quelles que soient les justifications, on a beau dire : « Voilà, je n'ai aucun lien » ou «
Je ne connais pas ces réseaux-là », eh bien, la suspicion va demeurer puisqu'on est véritablement dans un régime en fait de suspicion permanente.
Et donc moi, j'ai envie à un moment donné de prendre le contrepied et de retourner cette accusation contre elle-même,
pour que les détracteurs, finalement, se retrouvent dans la place de devoir eux-mêmes faire la démonstration de la dangerosité de ce qu'ils avancent.
Excellent. Et si je pose la même question alors à Kaoutar, un mot pour terminer, pour conclure ?
Oui, voilà, j'espère qu'avec cet échange, on a pu montrer un peu le relief de ce que représentait
la lutte contre l'islamophobie,
du caractère particulièrement genré qu'elle représente, mais qui fait aussi
émerger un peu de toutes ces fausses idées, notamment sur celle du patriarcat d'emblée, mais qui en réalité, voilà, répond à des logiques
plus complexes.
Et donc tout ça montre bien que voilà, cette lutte contre l'islamophobie est spécifique, et qu'elle doit être portée par les personnes qui sont concernées, parce que ce sont les mieux placées pour
mettre en place les dispositifs qui vont permettre de lutter contre et que la résistance de la société par rapport
à cette lutte et même à l'existence du mot islamophobie, eh bien, c'est une réponse qui démontre qu'on a raison dans cette lutte, en réalité, parce que c'est--
voilà, on a parlé des régimes d'exception, et Khadija a vraiment bien souligné qu'il s'agissait pas de dérives et c'est tout à fait vrai.
Donc c'est vraiment, il y a un parti pris là-dedans, etc.
Maintenant, il faut que la société se pose la question de : est-ce qu'à un moment, elle va
comprendre que le monde a changé et que maintenant, il faut évoluer et aller de l'avant ou est-ce qu'on va rester sur la crispation et le, disons,
le fait de nourrir les peurs à l'égard d'un ennemi intérieur, donc en mettant
sur l'échafaud tout un pan de la population et que ce pan de la population, aujourd'hui, si on analyse dans les détails, c'est celui qui fait les métiers dont plus personne ne veut,
c'est celui qui va faire que le rajeunissement de la population est assuré aussi.
Et donc, certains vont utiliser des idées pour faire peur en parlant de grand remplacement, etc. Mais avec des idées toujours négatives, de volonté, avec des objectifs cachés.
Mais vraiment, dans le fond des choses et dans
la réalité sociale,
ben y a rien à faire, les musulmans qui sont issus d'une immigration économique, en l'occurrence, et c'est ce qui fait la spécificité de l'immigration en Belgique, on participe pleinement au développement de la société.
Et donc toutes ces crispations participent à développer de la frustration de part et d'autre de la société.
Et y a rien à faire. À un moment, il faut passer aux choses sérieuses et se dire : « C'est bon, on a suffisamment fantasmé sur ces gens-là.
Comment on fait pour passer à la suite ? » Et en même temps, on a cet autre côté de nous-mêmes qui nous dit : « Malheureusement, nos sociétés occidentales sont inscrites dans un rapport conflictuel avec l'étrangeté
depuis très longtemps, depuis des siècles, c'est culturellement ancré.
» Donc, comment on va faire pour vivre dans une société, voilà, qui va hériter, qui aura cet héritage culturel pour avancer ?
Et la réponse, c'est que ben voilà, on s'organise politiquement pour y arriver, pour organiser nos luttes. Il ne nous reste plus qu'à nous souhaiter du courage pour arriver à plus de dignité, dans
dans cette société et de dignité pour toutes et tous.
Merci Kaoutar et Khadija pour ces échanges très intéressants. Je vous remercie encore une fois d'avoir accepté l'invitation.
J'étais ravi de pouvoir entendre-
Merci
...vos témoignages et vos opinions sur ces questions. Est-ce que les auditeurs, les auditrices peuvent vous retrouver quelque part, vous lire, vous-- donc on a mentionné la carte blanche de Khadija dans Le Vif.
Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres endroits où on peut vous suivre sur Internet ?
Oui, le collectif des cent diplômées. Donc sur Facebook, il y a une page Facebook. Et voilà, toute notre actualité se fait via ce collectif.
Excellent. Encore une fois, merci à toutes les deux. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Et voilà, j'espère que ça vous a plu. En ce qui me concerne, j'ai appris énormément de choses grâce à mes deux invitées au sujet de l'islamophobie.
J'espère que c'était le cas pour vous aussi. Quelques infos de service à présent. Dans deux semaines, je publierai mon interview avec Alice Coffin, qui est journaliste et militante française bien connue.
On va parler ensemble de la neutralité dans le journalisme, on va parler de lesbianisme politique. Ça va être super intéressant et ce sera donc le 23 septembre.
Et puis après ça, je publierai mon interview avec Ron Ohmas, sociologue à l'Université de Saint-Louis, pour parler ensemble de ses travaux de recherche au sujet de la prostitution.
Et enfin, deux semaines après ça, mon entretien avec Jean-Marc Jancovici, que je vous avais promis l'an dernier. Pour ne rien louper de tout ça, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée.
N'oubliez pas de suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur les réseaux sociaux : Facebook, Twitter ou même mon Instagram perso. Et n'hésitez pas à m'écrire, j'adore avoir vos feedbacks sur mon travail.
Et je précise, même si ça me paraît assez évident, je vous demande s'il vous plaît de ne pas m'écrire si c'est simplement pour exprimer votre désaccord profond avec mes deux invitées d'aujourd'hui,
sur la question de l'islamophobie ou de l'islam en général, ça ne m'intéresse pas du tout.
Allez, à très bientôt. Salut !